the number of children who had come to
America seeking asylum that have since
been detained has exploded to the
highest number ever recorded more than
five times higher than just last summer
of the 2654 children separated by the
Trump administration zero tolerance
policy 136 are still in US custody
without their parents three of them are
under five years old and the parents of
96 of those children have already been
deported
Lolita system most and most handling
jcpenney most was escape tenemos Corazon
que esto tiene que para esto no puede
seguir esta call that me Nieto s me
lucha get animals can say if you chant o
mundo we have no sister que esto no
pussy and I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry
I'm sorry
I'm sorry 100 times I'm sorry we love
you think you love you we love your
children and we will do something I
promise you it's strong together yeah we
will not be silenced
this summer hundreds of grandmothers
traveled from all over North America to
the US border with Mexico in McAllen
Texas day two with the grannies on a bus
day three I'm here with Raj Nam they had
the moment emotions are playing too much
and I don't know what to think
everything I'm looking at something I
feel like crying and I became at
something I feel we joined the original
caravan in New York City and made stops
at detention centers all across the
country these grandmother's wanted to
see with their own eyes what was
happening
their message of compassion and their
appeal for common-sense immigration
reform resonated all along the way until
the final stop in McAllen Texas the
first grandmother we met was Rosh
Hashanah a natural-born storyteller if I
prick you you're gonna bleed the same
color brother and if you're lucky enough
matching blood will be found for you
when you need it
right sitting alongside Rachna in a
cramped van for eight days I would
quickly be reminded of just how much
more we all have in common than there is
that divides us equally lightly that in
that refugee camp in that internment
camp there is somebody with the same
blood pool right along
so how are you any different from that
god me that's the same we are the ones
who have put the distance you're gonna
love Raj not okay
really Rachna is something else I'm
Rachna I have four grandchildren it's
easy and it's hard it's easy when you're
saying it 10 minutes later what the hell
was it
call me whatever you want her to this
smile but how do you frown and say if
you frown and she even if you got it
right I didn't hear you the first one I
met was and in New York she was actually
very good at a lot of things you know me
I love it any day she loves to talk on
the plane surprise surprise right
my grandmother was an immigrant my
parents were immigrants
I became an immigrant when I came here
in India I was born in India for so many
of the grandmothers there are personal
stories of discrimination of prejudice
and hatred in its ugliest forms is what
eventually motivated them to go on this
journey as parents and grandparents it
is our duty to make the world a safer
place you know my background is that I'm
a secular Jew and part of my identity is
that I need to stand up and fight for
justice when I saw these children the
pictures of them hiding up behind their
mothers the mothers looking so desperate
it brings back memories it brings back
conversations which I've had with my
grandmother with my father with extended
family members it comes back to you
because when my ancestors were refugees
it was people who was supposed to be the
enemy country Muslims ground place
Muslims what helping my family to cross
safely saying we're all one family so we
could be this could be a family portrait
let's take it ready family project on
day two russian ahmet edith her host in
pennsylvania if you don't mind asking my
age if you don't mind that 94 Wow
growing up in Nazi Germany
I saw what can happen when enough good
people don't do anything my mother and I
were sent off to Auschwitz we got to the
railroad station in and kept everybody
out of the Train and we walking along
the station and there's a German officer
and he said to my mother you go that way
and to me you go that way and I said but
that's my mother and he said well you
see her in 20 minutes
she's going on the bus and you will be
walking well that's the last I ever saw
her and then took me actually days to
find out what happened to the people who
had gone to the other side
they were sent to the gas chambers it's
sad that you haven't learned anything I
feel we have together involved people
you know you can't stand by and not do
anything so we are going this long way
to give those children love right we are
going to give them so much love and they
need to know that there is love we can
for them they need to know that this
morning though we're going to be seven
vehicles and a motorcycle missed him
here so this is Dan he came up with the
entire idea of going on this trip I just
wanted to like I don't know have like a
little moment where we just kind of like
not a prayer per se den is paternal he's
patient and he's pissed off I couldn't
get the image out of my head of my own
three-year-old being in a cage
and just like you know like it's one
thing that prisoners but children is
prisoners children have so many needs
all the time would he be trying to like
talk to another three year old and the
connects cage would he be asking the
other three-year-old where his mama is
so after watching the shocking news
unfold as the Trump administration began
separating children from their families
Dan took to Facebook and asked if a
group of grandmothers might want to
drive down to the border with Mexico
I like hadn't been able to cry it out or
anything I'd been like Oh
hold tight about everything and then I
watched that Rachel Maddow segment where
it was like load news and the world was
bad a journalist couldn't report it you
know Trump administration officials have
been sending babies to at least three
three tender age shelters in South Texas
lawyers and medical providers just think
I'm gonna have to hand this off there's
like centers where babies are detained
in jail and I like that she's I'm gonna
cry again and that segment just set me
off so bad I literally fell to the
ground I like just got on my knees and
sobbed out of like a week's worth of
crying that I wanted to do because I was
picturing my Henry
number is your funeral yeah my
three-year-old
SiC
then you know and then news there's so
much about hatred about how much every
community seems to be fighting and
hitting their the community but we were
so many grandmothers and others
youngsters also from all different parts
of the country and there's so much
nonsense about this is fake news and
that is fake news I am seeing for myself
what's actually happening I've read it
in the news and it hurts me that human
beings can treat each other that way
especially educated caring human beings
and we are aren't you
it wasn't just that rosna had all the
answers she also somehow had all the
right questions to you and I hear people
saying that these people don't deserve
it what do you need people they're all
people in what way are you different
from the person over there
in what way you both have two eyes
we'll both
it would have that one brain how much
you lose it is a different story
there is one brain it be unite no child
can support no time there's no question
of your child of my kind or this time no
big children and that's all denied
so we just crossed the border from
Brownsville Texas into Mexico as you can
see under this blue tarp there are some
of the people who are going to be
seeking asylum they tell us that they're
waiting their turn they were told that
they have to come back because it's too
busy estoy esperando amiga 4k a leonis
it appeared as helo I started off a
little decorum o sk i conflict on radio
intrados pueblo stallion go si este
tiene miedo 4 k IM print am en toda t
are you
I was looking this side at the beautiful
sunset and wondering when the American
dream became an American Nightmare so
that's what it feels like to me
feels like a nightmare we are America
the Beautiful why are we destroying it
we should be proud everybody wants to
come here or the hard-working people
want to come here and uplift us we join
hands with them
I'm not sick this is all emotion coming
out
[Music]
you